this course in bioinformatics is a good  place to start it will provide you with  a full roadmap to go from a to z or from  basics to advanced and cutting-edge  bioinformatics methods in the context of  projects that you can learn from we call  this roadmap omixlogic it consists of  online coursework interactive tutorials  as well as projects and data sets from  peer-reviewed research articles  to get started you will need a solid  overview of key technologies that are  used to generate data omix technologies  these courses will include  practical exercises to see how this data  can be analyzed and guidance on  developing a project of your own using  various analytical tools and publicly  available biological data in the next  few lessons we will review important  terminology provide perspectives from  experts in this exciting field and  review how quizzes allow you to see what  you have learned including assignments  for hands-on practice